zach davies has been brilliant his last
two outings he will face jazz chisholm
in the air toward the left a long run
but on the run and making the grab is
jack
peterson
here is jesus aguilar 49 runs batted in
in the air to left
peterson into the track and
[Applause]
we get our first look at right-hander
cody poteet
p-o-t-e-e-t the cubs they're four games
in new york all the runs they scored all
nine game by way of the home run
peterson drives one toward right center
and
touchdown
[Applause]
and that's got this place rocking it's
an energized crowd to begin with right
over the 368
marker i barely had time to call that
home run it left the park so quickly
javier baez
16 home runs a leadoff home run for
peterson the walk to bryant now the
pitch tobias which is hit high in the
air and out to deep left field backing
up his sanchez and he leaps and he makes
the catch at the wall
packed house on a friday night
and you get a baseball a challenge
back to the corner
baez knows it's either gone or it's
caught and indeed it is caught that is
not an easy catch folks jorge
alfaro is the batter jorge hitting 256.
ouch right back at davies and over to
third on the deflection the throw anyway
he is safe at first and make sure
davies is okay it's kind of a defense
defensive reaction here comes david ross
so with one out the bases are full
starling popped up to the second baseman
in the first inning
3-2
and mrs lowe again walks in a run
marlins tie it
base has loaded two down a one-to-one
tie third inning and adam duvall who
grounded out to short his first time
steps in
and adam duvall with the drive out to
left field this is gone grand slam adam
duvall
that's the big hit the marlins needed
yeah change up trying to go down and
away and it just floated out over the
plate a little bit and uh duvall just
leaned on it
warm night at wrigley doesn't take much
scott peterson homer to right center his
first
time right
peterson
two advanced two home runs
first time he got the fastball this time
he gets the slow ball the straight
change do the dance jock
[Applause]
unloading for the second time
a change up
demolished
davies
that rough third inning the grand slam
duval
a five run inning for the marlins
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bounced up off that
left knee
[Applause]
easy grab it short
maya's out number two davies could use a
quick inning and he's positioned to do
so two quick outs here comes the
one ground ball deep in the hole of
short oh backhanded stop fires up on his
feet throws to first in time to get
aguilar
another sensational defensive play by
javier
adam duvall with the game's big blow if
you missed it a grand slam back in the
third plastic the cubs bullpen is
and duvall left field that's going to
drop in for a base hit a multi-hit
effort for adam duvall
davies stays in
with two down and two on
and the third baseman for the marlins
john bertie
oh john birdie fly ball left field this
one is gonna go
another home run at wrigley field for
john bernie
a three run shot to blow it open
they'll fly away bernie you love you
some wrigley field don't you
wow gets it done again
starling martay
a walk in the third
digs in here against dan winkler
was done in that series of course didn't
play in the series against the atlanta
braves either
[Applause]
two for three the grand slam has scored
twice
and duvall fly ball left field gives
this one a ride peterson turns a
multi-homer game for adam duvall
when he gets hot he gets hot 10-2
marlins on top zach popp is still in the
game for miami half is over for three a
pair of strikeouts and a fly out to
right
as this one is grounded to first pop
gets to the bag right before half that's
out number one one down and sergio
alcantara is the batter
one and two
and a called strike three 95 at the top
of the zone and the marlins are an out
away from taking the opener of this
three-game series
[Music]
jake mariznick
a strikeout
and now a chopper to third birdie makes
the play over to first it's a marlins
win 10-2 the final score
after the day off the marlins bats come
to life adam duvall with a big day six
rbis couple of home runs
as don mattingly and the marlins take
the opener of this three-game series at
wrigley field
a much needed offensive outburst they
snapped their four-game losing streak in
which they had scored only seven runs
solid but they get 10 tonight